the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's look at storyboard 17 panel a so
far in 507 we've looked in detail at
carbohydrate catabolism we've seen that
the complete catabolism of a molecule of
glucose by way of glycolysis pyruvate
dehydrogenase and the TCA cycle results
in the generation of about 36 to 38
molecules of ATP at this point we're
going to turn to catabolism of another
metabolic fuel lipids as we'll see
lipids because they contain more energy
per gram because they're more highly
reduced in carbohydrates will produce
much more ATP per unit weight than
carbohydrates for example if we were to
metabolize hexanoic acid the six carbon
hydrocarbon the same number of carbons
as glucose we get over 58 EPS rather
than about 35 ATP s4 molecule which we
would have got from glucose now let's
look at panel B lipids have many roles
in biological systems the first that
will be relevant to this lecture is that
there are primary energy reserve in fact
about 80% of our stored energy is in the
form of lipid second as Joanne taught us
lipids are key components of biological
membranes and thus they contribute in a
major way to the compartmentalization
that's critical for normal biological
functions and the third role is that
some lipids are signaling molecules the
one I pictured here is estradiol well
estradiol may not look like a typical
lipid it actually is indeed it's made by
a lipid biosynthetic pathway that starts
with sotl coenzyme a and we'll see later
that acetic away also serves as the
precursor for the canonical lipid a
fatty acid fatty acids are d classic
lipid their hydrocarbon chains that are
fully saturated or contain a small
number of double bonds
and sometimes branches sometimes the
fatty acid moiety is esterified to the
backbone of glycerol if you have three
fatty acids on a glycerol backbone one
to each of the hydroxyl groups
that's called a tri a so glyceride
that's our primary storage form of
energy with phospholipids one of the
hydroxyl groups of the glycerol backbone
is esterified to either phosphate or
some kind of decorated phosphate with
the decoration could be a sugar or some
other moiety as we've seen in Joanne's
lectures phospholipids are the key
building blocks of biological membrane
now take a look at panel D the rest of
this lecture will deal with the details
of how fatty acids are broken down to
carbon dioxide with the intermediate
production of reducing equivalents in
the form of nadh and fadh2 and
ultimately energy equivalents in the
form of ATP cells can acquire lipids
directly from the blood where typically
they're transported by albumin they can
come directly from our diet or from
other organs or from breakdown of tri
acyl glycerides within our cells we're
going to be looking at four steps in
fatty acid catabolism the first step
involves the appearance of the fatty
acid in the cytoplasm of the cell the
fatty acid can come in either from
breakdown of a trial glyceride stored in
the cytoplasm or the fatty acid could
appear from transport across the
membrane from the blood in the cytoplasm
the fatty acid which is technically a
carboxylic acid will be thio esterified
to form a fatty acyl coenzyme a the
second step of fatty acid catabolism
involves the transport of the fatty acyl
coenzyme a ester into the mitochondrion
which is the site of fatty acid
oxidation the third step in fatty acid
catabolism involves the actual oxidation
process itself the series of reactions
is called beta oxidation beta oxidation
results in the conversion of the
carboxylic acid starting material to
acetyl coenzyme a there can be several
fates to the acetyl co a produced by
beta oxidation but the one we're going
to be looking at is its entry into the
TCA cycle where the so2
is metabolized to carbon dioxide with
the generation of reducing equivalents
those reduced electron carriers have the
potential to be converted into energy
currency in the form of ATP the fourth
topic or stage in fatty acid catabolism
that we'll deal with concerns
specialized endings of the catabolic
pathway the first problem that will look
at concerns the fact that some fatty
acids have an odd number of carbons in
them whereas the classical fatty acid
beta oxidation system was primarily
designed to process fatty acids with
even numbers of carbon units the second
problem that we'll look at as an ending
of fatty acid oxidation concerns the
fact that some of the fatty acids in our
diet have a double bond that is either
in the wrong stereochemistry or is in
the wrong place to enable easy
metabolism
Nature has worked out ways to reposition
the double bond to facilitate the entry
of the molecule into classical beta
oxidation schemes let's look now at
panel II the first step in fatty acid
catabolism involves thio esterification
of the carboxylate residue of the fatty
acid we're going to see in a couple of
minutes that placing a coenzyme a moiety
on the carboxylate is going to enable
chemistry at the beta carbon without the
coenzyme a group chemistry at the beta
carbon would be impossible the enzyme
involved is called fatty acyl coenzyme a
synthetase sometimes called ligase and
it additionally goes by the more common
name thio kinase this enzyme uses ATP to
identity our box elate residue and then
it allows coenzyme a to replace the a MP
residue with the resulting product being
a fatty acyl coenzyme a this reaction
happens in the cytoplasm of the cell
beta oxidation however is going to occur
in the mitochondrial matrix so we have
to find a way to get this fatty acyl
coenzyme a into the mitochondrial matrix
let's go now to storyboard eighteen
panel a panel a shows the cytoplasm the
mitochondrial outer membrane the inter
membrane space the inner membrane and
the my
andreal matrix as I just said the matrix
is going to be the site at which beta
oxidation occurs the intermembrane space
contains a small alcohol called
carnitine and the mitochondrial outer
membrane contains an enzyme called
carnitine acyl transferase one or cat
one cat one removes the acyl group from
the fatty acyl coenzyme a in the
cytoplasm and transfers it to the
alcoholic residue in the center of the
carnitine molecule forming an ester of
the fatty acid with carnitine this ester
is delivered to cat two which is
embedded in the inner membrane on the
matrix side cat two will then transfer
the ACL functionality to a coenzyme a
restoring the fatty acyl coenzyme a
molecule
thus cat one and cat two working in a
concerted way result in the effective
transfer of a fatty acyl coenzyme a from
the cytoplasm into the mitochondrial
matrix the site of beta oxidation which
will be our next step let's now look at
panel B this panel shows an inset with
the mitochondrial inner membrane the
electron transfer complex and ETF P the
electron transferring flavor protein
which is going to be the entry point of
electrons from the initial step of
oxidation of the fatty acyl Co way into
the electron transport chain we also see
in this panel the fatty acid palmitate
the C 16 straight chain carboxylic acid
the hydrogen beta to the coenzyme a
ester is relatively acidic therefore
this hydrogen will be taken off to form
an alkene and the hydride will be
transferred from the dated carbon the
third carbon from the right those
electrons are transferred to a flavin in
the electron transferring flavor protein
ETF P eventually those electrons are
transferred to coenzyme q to form the
reduced form of coenzyme q those
electrons then travel along through the
electron transport chain the organic
product of this reaction is a trans inna
wheel coenzyme
eh now let's take a look at panel C in
the next step water is added to the
three carbon of the inna wheel coenzyme
a resulting product is a three hydroxy
fatty acyl coenzyme a we've seen
oxidation of alcohols that look
something like this many times
for example malate being oxidized by
malate dehydrogenase to oxaloacetate and
as we've seen before the hydroxyl group
is converted to a keto functionality
hydride transfer goes to nad plus to
form NADH the enzyme that does this
conversion is three hydroxy fatty acyl
coenzyme a dehydrogenase at this point
we have generated one fadh2 and one NADH
in the overall process of the beta
oxidation scheme the three keto ACL
coenzyme a is now set up to release a
first molecule of acetyl coenzyme a the
enzyme beta keto thiolase is assisting
on it the thigh all of the cysteine will
attack the carbon that has the keto
group and release acetylcholine xym a
the residue is a thio ester in which the
residual 14 carbons of the palmitate
that we started with are now connected
to beta keto thiolase lastly beta keto
thiolase will transfer this residual 14
carbons to a coenzyme a molecule forming
the fatty acyl coenzyme a that will be
14 carbons long that is it's two carbons
shorter than the 16 carbons of palmitate
that we started with overall this
process is called beta oxidation the
system is now set up to allow the 14
carbon molecule to go to 12 to 10 and so
on until the entire 16 carbon
hydrocarbon has been reduced through
seven rounds of beta oxidation to eight
molecules of acid Hil coenzyme a if
these eight molecules of acetyl co a are
further oxidized by the TCA cycle you'll
get 96 ATP molecules and of course along
the way in each round of beta oxidation
you will also produce seven fadh2s
seven fadh2s will be converted into 14
ATP's
you will also get seven nadh s and they
will be converted into 21 ATP's so the
full conversion of the sixteen carbon
hydrocarbon palmitate will result in a
total of 131 ATP's in order to put
together a full balance sheet however
keep in mind that we needed to use
several ATP's early in the process in
order to prime the system that is fatty
acyl coenzyme a synthetized use two high
energy phosphate bonds in order to prime
the fatty acid for production of the
coenzyme a intermediate that's necessary
for beta oxidation